et
[Musique]
une activité fébrile règne sur la terre
les shadoks pour s'y reconnaître ont
décidé de la rangée au mans
ranger la terre dans un sens remarquez
bien ce n'était pas une mauvaise idée
si les shadoks avait réussi cela aurait
une folle avoué des conséquences tout à
fait intéressante pour les générations
futures
notamment ce qui concerne l'enseignement
de la géographie carte de la terre
aurait été à peu près ainsi la montagne
la terre la côte
la mère ordinaire molle et la mer dure
un point c'est tout on n'aurait pas
perdu le temps qu'on a perdus pendant
des générations et des générations a
découvert des contenants plus ou moins
lointain et hypothétique et à faire
l'inventaire de toutes ces îles îlots
archipel qui infestent pratiquement la
sopac nerfs et chaud cause de tant
d'accidents d'avant il n'y aurait même
pas eu besoin de bateaux du tout puisque
on n'aurait pas eu à aller vers ses
rivages lointains n'y à plus forte
raison à henry mais combien de marins
combien de capitaines en restant
tranquillement au coin du feu aurait pu
s'éviter la peine de ne jamais revenir
dans ces conditions le métier de marin
aurait été le plus beau métier du monde
tout le monde aurait été marin et la
paix aurait régné
malheureusement ça s'est pas fait et
pourtant pendant des générations et des
générations les shadoks compères
grattait passait ils puissent
transporter et son répit sa charte
il fit défi des rires et des pme saluons
quand même ici le courage et
l'abnégation de ces innocentes bêtes qui
se livrèrent corps et âme à cette noble
tâche
tâche d'autant plus noble qu'il faisait
tous ça au péril de leur vie et sans
aucun résultat appréciable tac d'autant
plus périlleuse que le déménagement
s'effectue est bien entendu sans
l'accord du propriétaire qui pour le
moment continuer à faire la fête avec
ses amis déjà dit mais quel est il se
passer
[Musique]